on est appelé l'été cocktails classiques
peu de forêt on est appelés sur un
événement sur un gros feu de forêt
et puis tout dégénère on doit se mettre
en auto protection dans notre camion le
groupe éclate
au moment de mettre de notre notre dos
protection sur le camion
le camion dysfonctionne
et là en fait on se retrouve dans un
camion sans joints de portes hier avec
un plancher corrodé
sans air pour respirer les fumées
et il brûle et on est dedans et la
formation que défend ce monsieur sait
rester dans le camion
aujourd'hui le camion il n'en reste rien
on a compris qu'on a dû remettre en
question la formation qu'on nous a reçus
ce jour là et on nous le reproche
j'entends aujourd'hui
c'est que si on était resté dans son
camion il serait devenu notre cercueil
et quand on est sorti du camion au
moment où j'allais ouvrir la vanne pour
mme aspergé d'eau parce qu'il était
plein mon collègue jeremy veillard tombé
au sol et il crie à l'aide
et à ce moment là je décide d'aller
chercher il faisait 1200 degrés
au moment où je vais le chercher pour le
relever il prend feu
il prend feu devant moi et je le regarde
pendant trois quatre minutes
et vous savez quel boussaha ça c'est
commode c'est comme le bout des doigts
que vous faites en cuisine ça a le goût
de la présomption d'innocence
c'est incroyable votre histoire lucas
s'arrêter c'est un témoignage très fort
donc
qui reprocher donc à ce peut-être futur
candidat de koh lanta c'est d'abord
donner des mauvaises informations les
désordres qui vous ont mis dans une
situation inextricable puisqu'ils vous
ont demandé dans com vous livre de
rester dans le camion alors qu'il aurait
fallu quitter le camion plus vite et un
moment vous l'avez quittée comme vous
l'avez dit sinon le camion serait devenu
votre cercueil
aujourd'hui la production de koh lanta
dit qu'elle n'était pas au courant
parle de présomption d'innocence
et pourtant le 10 août 2016 quelques
heures après l'accident plusieurs
altercations ont eu à l'hôpital
avec nos officiers supérieurs et les
pompiers mais le pire dans tout ça c'est
que le 26 août 2016 le 10 à otis a osé
sortir un communiqué qui a déclenché la
procédure ou le 10 10
dans un instant de panique et dans un
instinct de survie les quatre occupants
du ccf numéro trois ont quitté eux mêmes
le camion et ont concouru à eux mêmes à
leurs propres dommages nous nous étions
dans le coma la présomption d'innocence
ils en bénéficient où nous n'en avons
jamais bénéficié
aujourd'hui
certains
parlent de la saison de koh lanta comme
maudite puisque le nom de totem en
maudit moi je représente aujourd'hui le
totem de la vérité que je porte encore
sur mon corps aujourd'hui tout vous êtes
dans la vraie vie lucas et vous ce qui
vous est arrivé c'est pas un jeu c'est
pas un jeu d'enfant ce qui m'énerve
aujourd'hui c'est que sur votre plateau
malgré qu'on ne venait pas bénéficié
certains brême
prennent un totem
c'est le totem de la présomption
d'innocence
pour boucliers pour effacer ce qui s'est
passé mais moi j'aimerais passer deux
messages à nos gouvernants
monsieur emmanuel macron
expliquez moi pourquoi depuis le 10 août
les trois autres occupants du ccf numéro
n'ont toujours pas la légion d'honneur
nous ne sommes pas présumé innocent
et puis j'ai un mot pour monsieur
darmanin également
ce qui s'est passé ce jour là et je le
sais et beaucoup le savent il ya eu un
dysfonctionnement sur le camion aux feux
de forêt qui est grave
et on est six ans après l'administration
n'a rien fait
aujourd'hui on a des chefs qui se
permettent de se présenter à kolontar
qui se permettent de violer les articles
du code du travail de mettre en danger
des sapeurs-pompiers et je vous le dis
aujourd'hui
il ya un dysfonctionnement général sur
les camions citernes feux de forêts en
france et l'administration ne fait rien
alors je vous regarde cyril
monsieur darmanin j'ai repris mes études
en alternance cette année je m'occupe de
la sécurité des travailleurs
demain si vous le souhaitez je serais
ravi d'aider la direction générale de la
sécurité civile à écrire les procédures
qui n'ont jamais été écrites